tall Inquisition field agents multiple  reports one of hi dragons moving into  island ruins under Ferelden coast you  know the damage that just one of these  creatures can do we must strike before  their rampage destroys the most of the  stone I have authorised three new agents  to join in this fight  the Sky Watcher brings to bear the other  dream to make some elemental magic and  many  zither call them tougher virtuosa and  may actually deserve the title the man  controls a broad range of magic through  his looped which can alter the flow of  battle for Oliver and Isabella so called  admiral and queen of the eastern seas is  an unmatched duelist she strives from  anywhere and is nearly prepare carefully  for what you will face  well dance sexy huh guess